in five four three two welcome everybody
to another episode of the genius brain
podcast we're trying to do this podcast
without headphones now because I don't
think I really need it oh really I get
pretty loud though David do you yeah let
me see go ahead testers I'm like a
council lady that just like screams all
most of the time do can you believe this
[ __ ] I can't believe all this she was
just happening all at once that's
perfect okay that's fine we go we got
audio stuff but today is a special guest
we have a returning guest man because
you know we actually recorded two
episodes before but I forgot to record
the audio on it so we didn't get to put
it up is that what happened legit I just
thought of it oh no I guess I guess the
content wasn't clear no it wasn't that
the audio was [ __ ] up is because my my
car died and so I didn't realize that
and so when I put it in everything was
invalid and all the files died in it I
thought least one of them did but I
switched the cards in between cuz I you
say every time I did it take I used to
switch cards out so thank God I did
because we got to keep that one take so
now you're here wow I don't even know I
mean whatever it's okay yeah dude
the lady from JK who never wanted to be
on camera the first place where she's on
camera now did given I was blessed with
the opportunity we've been blessed with
an opportunity she started off with one
JK member she weaseled away and that's
how I started so we were talking we were
having lunch and julia has this we have
this ritual where we hang out you'll get
a massage so today I thought I was gonna
be pretty good about it
because I was like man finance there's a
little tight right it's like but I'm
seeing David and haven't seen David in a
while and I feel like it's been about a
year since we actually hung out one on
one yeah and it was around the same time
as last year when we film genius
broadcast as it was yet and I just
remember I was driving over to CEO like
man you know what sounds good right now
a massage did we we always go to the
same place and if you get a couples
massage you get $20 off so it's it's so
[ __ ] good dude but we go every time
and every time this [ __ ] gets a massage
it's the funniest thing
cuz if you guys have never gotten an
asian massage before basically what
happens is these tiny little Asian women
they [ __ ] you up
they they will but for her she's
completely fine she has a really high
threshold for pain so for me I was
falling asleep through about I see about
thirty minutes of it and the woman
started stepping on my calves but I wake
up to the sound of her going
can you go harder please I don't
understand this it hurts
it feels good like the amount of the
amount of pressure it is harder the
better because I just feel like it just
releases all the tension but I I did
hear you sleep you're like literally
this you're like and then as soon as the
lady stepped on your calves you're like
they have really strong ladies man like
I remember before I used to get you know
you know like a Massage Envy and a lot
of those like white people massages and
even some of their like sport massages
it doesn't feel as hard as a asian
massage really yeah like asian massage
just kind of go really hard but it
really depends like if you go to a
specialist they'll really work into like
knots and stuff but you people I think
always go a lot deeper dang I don't know
I always it go harder how hard do you
want it you want them to hit your
ribcage like what you want I just want a
good enough pressure to release my knots
but like I know not to take time to kind
of release you know but it's just like I
just wanted to like just get in there
and just rub right in there you're
[ __ ] crazy because you know when I
give you massages sometimes like you
really just like right there right and I
dig into it you mean like a little
harder I'm like [ __ ] god damn it dude
give me give me a tip this is exhausting
I give like bark massages and then it
doesn't you like it even harder than
Bart likes it really yeah I don't know
Bart whenever I tried a massage Bart
he's just one solid rock yeah I'm like I
don't even think my thumbs are effective
at this yeah you have to put body weight
on him cuz he's so just muscular yeah
like there's no gap in his body I mean
it's just like my body feels like a bag
full of jello like his body feels like a
big-ass piece of brisket yeah I mean you
should try to work that muscle this
super hard
yeah so apparently we found out
well he found out recently just because
I haven't been on JK party it since like
his first inception back in the day like
JK party was never really my thing so I
never wanted to come on well you were
featured on it because of behind the
scenes because of some JK scale oh that
was the original mm-hmm cuz JK party was
meant to be behind the scenes yeah for
JK films and then eventually we added
like adventures into it so it'll be
going out to places to eat or places to
visit and then we slowly started to
integrate challenges into it and then
became like a game show
that's right and then there was like
mafia that was like one of the bigger
bigger things which is which is so funny
cuz I didn't know people didn't know
that about the game mafia until because
it was a church game so I used to play
it at church all the time we're just so
weird because it's about gangsters
shooting innocent people true I mean it
could be generally anything I mean the
fun part about mafia isn't so much the
discovery for me anyway is the fun part
about mafia was it dependent on who was
telling the story the storyteller was
always the most exciting person cuz they
would make you funny or not funny yes
yes oh you're a great yes I was I was
the first person who introduced mafia to
the group it was it was specifically I
think it was at Danielle's house is when
Danielle used to be a part of JK and
then I introduced the game of mafia
there damn I don't think I was there for
that time you were not around there at
the time yeah so that's that was before
that's pre ex blue apples day for you
and then since then like JK party became
that thing where you guys are always
playing mafia and it was like a super
fun thing but it was it was one of those
things so it's like it's a game but
sometimes people get heated at it like
you get so mad when people try to kill
you is like no [ __ ]
I'm not mafia I'm a [ __ ] nurse that's
a competitive everyone is yeah what are
you gonna miss the most about JK party
oh there's so many things I'm gonna miss
I think I'm gonna definitely miss seeing
everybody at least once a week yeah once
a week I mean - all the prep work and
like the post work of it I really enjoy
just seeing everyone the day of and just
literally playing games yeah that was it
it was it was just a fun time and I love
the idea that oh hey I'm going to work
today what are you doing at work games
yeah yeah
how long were the shoots for JK party
they would start around ten and then we
would end around six so about maybe
eight hours was a long [ __ ] day did I
guess seven hours with one lunch one
yeah that's pretty [ __ ] long that's a
good JK news day almost yeah yeah we try
to pack as many videos as we can within
a day
damn so how many how many videos would
you guys shoot we would try for at least
six videos and then if we go ahead and
go up to eight or nine that we great
damn yeah so what were you doing for JK
party specifically because originally
you were were you just a cast member yes
I was a cast member and then eventually
as geo and Michael was transitioning out
I was brought in to kind of help test
out games because I just had more time
and I just wanna say if you guys ever
need anything I can always help you guys
and so really yeah cool come on in
test out some games with us see what you
think see what you like do you think
that it'll it's part of the brand or not
part of the brand and so I was a part of
the those those meetings and then
eventually it became like okay cool so
we're gonna leave JK party and then
Jimmy party's gonna go into like your
guys his hands they were like okay well
I mean like initially like Aaron wanted
to to take it over yeah and then so he
asked me and B Troy to help him out with
it mhm and then from there and
transition and it was me and B joy oh
wow well I think that's the the
interesting thing to like when people
see videos online they don't understand
the the work that kind of goes behind it
right and I think like with JK - there
was a time where all of us really had a
you know things were going really well
and then we just we expanded a lot yeah
so I explained it was a huge boom we had
those two huge offices there was a huge
set which people don't even realize how
big that [ __ ] said was it was it was
such an interesting time and it was just
a lot to handle - I think in terms of
like having to create those games and
have them be that consistent because
before in YouTube like if you did one
video a week you were fine but
algorithmically it doesn't make any
sense Moore's about frequency now so
that I think you guys went from doing
like a video per week and doing multiple
videos per week and I was like how the
[ __ ] are you guys gonna keep up with
this [ __ ]
we figured out a way we figured out a
way and um yeah it was one video to two
videos to three and then I think we got
up to either five or six videos released
a week on party hmmm no more no more no
more JK party now man it's time to move
on yeah time to move on so what's your
next move
you know honestly I don't know I don't
know I feel like a lot of things are
open the air I'll probably stay on
YouTube with my own channel or either
that actually like maybe find a job in
something that I've always wanted to do
which is production for animation but
we'll see you have vlogs from like seven
years ago [ __ ] I have not seen a single
one where the [ __ ] are they Wow
thanks for keeping up with my channel
have you put up the last video that I
put up was about me making my own boba
drinks thank you very much David what
did that come out that came out in
November mid November is hell a long
time ago and before that what was your
previous video exactly are you talking
about I just want to prove you wrong but
no no I get it though I get it now I
just post all your old vlogs cuz you
look so different in them back Friday
series but it seemed like nobody was
really that interested in it they just
wanted to know what was happening now
yeah but you never promoted it though I
guess you'll be promoted cuz I didn't
know about it okay well look I got a lot
of footage I got a lot of fun you have a
lot of footage I remembered you bought
the whole camera and everything I I you
know what I have not even posted about
TIF encases wedding yeah but I had like
great foot Oh KC and TIFF sweaty you
don't you didn't post any of it no you
should I'm so good I'm actually curious
cuz I want to know what that's like
because I think that's a cool thing
about yeah vlogging is cool in a sense
of I kind of like it within that group
setting because everybody has a
different perspective even though it was
the same thing right because there was a
time where I started vlogging and then I
kind of mentioned it over to Barton Joe
and I was telling them about why
vlogging is important because of how it
kind of like it helps you connect the
fans a lot and that's why I originally
like vlogging a lot and then I got tired
of it so I stopped doing it but then you
know Barton geode they [ __ ] smashed
at it they were killing in hell yeah
nealy vlogs yeah I thought that was
insane I was like dude and Jojo was like
smashing at it too he was doing such a
great job you know and then now I think
like it kind of moved like I moved away
from that too but it was a great way for
people to kind of like connect to their
fans aside from their regular content
right right and then vlogging was like
such a huge craze everybody and their
mom was [ __ ] blogging you know I felt
like out of all the vlogs
within JK or the JK friends mm-hmm yours
was the most beautiful well I put too
much time into mind like if you look up
if you guys know I like I went to Taiwan
I did this whole mini like Taiwan series
I loved it it was beautiful
I nearly [ __ ] died shooting that [ __ ]
though cuz I brought I brought all my
own lobs by the way the audio I did
myself the the shooting I did myself so
like I was carrying like a 50 pounds to
be exaggerating but it was a very very
large backpack filled with lenses that I
would shoot every day dump unload dump
unload and I got really hyped when I
what the Taiwan cuz I was like I want to
do this but I got roughly about 4 or 5
videos out of it but then after that
that was only for about three or four
days of shooting but I was better for
about two weeks because I couldn't do it
anymore because I was killing my back
I'm carrying all this equipment so I
could stop shooting but it was fun well
Aston what a merio thing because I knew
I know that you're traveling with me you
know I think she enjoyed it but this is
where we also find out when Mary when I
found out that we we couldn't really
work together right so anybody out there
who knows like in theory it's always
great thing like oh I couldn't work with
my partner but there's a lot of like
dips and caveats that you don't really
see like for example like being in love
with somebody and hanging out with him
is different than being the more
informed one in the group and what
you're telling them what to do as a boss
oh that's where it becomes different
right yeah and like if Meryl and I
worked on something together I wouldn't
really be her boss but I would be the
person who has ten plus years experience
in entertainment so my opinion would
matter more right in terms of like
certain things right that it comes to
what we're developing
however because she's my girlfriend my
opinion doesn't mean [ __ ] sometimes
there's feelings feelings matter now so
for example let's say we were shooting
something I'm not saying she did this
but I could already foresee it because
it happens in our
a relationship a lot so let's say like
there's a part of a video that goes that
I don't really like I'm like that's not
a really good shot like the lighting is
really bad I think we should trash it
because it's not good I'm guessing what
would come out is I guess you know I'll
be like what you mean I guess right I
don't think it's a good shot she goes no
you just don't you just don't like you
know and anything that I shot you think
it's all bad so whatever it's okay and
then it's gonna lead to this other fight
where it goes like why do you gotta talk
to my bad work is work work is work and
our relationship is our relationship is
like no you just don't like anything I
do he'll just start getting into a fight
so I'm like I don't want to touch this
this podcast is brought to you by fiber
my friends let's talk about freelance
talent for your business or project
because finding the right freelancer can
be time-consuming and it can be
frustrating and expensive well Fiverr
has your back because thanks to fiber
finding the right freelancer doesn't
have to be a struggle I have struggled
finding freelance or it because number
one sometimes when you don't have people
like fiber on your back you have to set
up these random guidelines you don't
know when you're gonna get these
projects well fiber kind of makes
everything easy so before I even pick
out an artist well I look at their art
and then I see when they can deliver the
said projects that I need at what time
what cost and what assets I receive it's
all laid out there you don't have to
think about much you just have to think
about if you want their service or not
in the due time that they say they can
deliver and then my friends you are good
to go 24/7 customer service you'll know
exactly what you're paying for upfront
no negotiating knee did take five and
check out fiber comm and you will
receive 10% off your first order by
using my code g/b it's so easy don't
waste any more time and get their
service you deserve by going to FIV eat
our comm code GB fiber it starts here
because it happened a little bit when we
were when I was helping her with her
Instagram and I saw a glimpse outside
glimpse of how we could fight so I
decide not to do it yeah yeah yeah yeah
but I mean her the Instagram that's like
made public yeah I feel like it looks
real good yeah I mean she's just having
having fun with it and then Instagram
became such a job though you know it
wasn't did you get was she getting brand
deals yeah she gets brand more brands
than I do nice you know I mean they're
smaller brand deals but people always
inquire because girls sell better than
guys do you guys always do better I
don't know I guess so I mean I can see
it I can see it I think for me it's just
like I think in my head I'm always
feeling oh you know worthy of these
brand deals you're great you have a
really strong following bill you're
following is [ __ ] strong there's a
lot of girls who you know have your
similar following but they don't get the
same amount of interactions I think
that's the difference is that people who
follow you and like you they they they
genuinely like die hard for you thank
you oh my god yeah you could tell by
like interactions on your Instagram cuz
those people who have like 2 million
followers but they get like eight
thousand likes 7,000 likes the ratio
doesn't really make sense because you
know I don't think they really connect
with people very well and a lot of their
photos are them being cool versus them
being themselves yeah and that's the
hard part right I mean cuz for you when
you when you came on to this platform
did you find it hard to did you feel
like you had to be somebody else or did
you find it hard to be herself I would
say a little bit of both because when I
first joined in I kind of knew who I was
but then I was open to try to be a
different person or to form into a
different person and I I would say there
was a good amount where I would post
photos that I was just excited about
like genuinely excited oh this is so fun
I just want to share it right and then
there are times I was like oh I think
this photo would do well because it's
kind of like a call back or a reference
to what we did you know so it was a
little bit of both but I tried to keep
it to my own voice and I try to keep it
to what I like so the way that I like to
treat my Instagram is memories I love to
share oh yeah how often do you post if
I'm making a lot of great memories every
day but if not then maybe I'll try at
least like minimum once or twice a week
yeah it's it's hard for me to post that
often like I'm trying my best you know
but it's because I mean it's cool that
people want to know what
going on and we want to share this
information with everybody but then
sometimes it's hard because like I feel
like it's being forced yeah and I know I
and I never did Instagram for it to be a
business opportunity it was just because
I wanted to share photos and share my
life because I thought it was really
cool versus Facebook at the time when
Facebook if you were sharing your life
yeah there was photos but it was through
status updates right you would write it
down but with pictures pictures say a
thousand words you don't have really
have to say much you just had the photo
up and then people could see it and now
we're like as a society where you could
kind of like lie about how you're doing
and how you're feeling and it always
made me feel disingenuous so it's like
if I was upset and even now if I'm
[ __ ] pissed or upset I'm not gonna
post a happy photo I same-same so like
if I'm not feeling so hot I'm like I
don't really want to post anything on
Instagram yeah but I know a lot of
people who do that like they'll like
I'll literally see them and they'll get
into a fight with like there's
significant other or look into a car
crash or whatever right and the next
photo is when I see you like ten minutes
later it's dude life is great you know I
mean just chilling in the Sun today and
I'm like [ __ ] you got to a seven car
pileup what are you talking about eight
out of eight and it's you know I feel
like sometimes it's hard for people
especially like in your case because I
don't think you ever came into the space
to be somebody in entertainment and it
just kind of became something that you
fell into yeah I mean it was it was a
nice surprise I would say I like even
though I didn't come in to - yeah to be
an entertainment or to be like a face or
some sort of influencer I I don't know I
feel like I'm very blessed even had that
opportunity because the only reason why
it happened was um I think it was for a
JK party game or something and I
remember the guys and and Gio were like
oh we need a girl Julia you go up I was
like what and I was like me and I was
like just behind the camera under like
yeah yeah yeah we need more girls in
there I'm like okay so I just went in
there cuz like I mean to me I was like
okay I want to try it looks fun right
and I tried it and they're like you're
not cool we're just gonna have you in
front of camera I'm like oh yeah really
yeah it was kind of like that and then I
think I think what also helped with that
part of that transition to was hosting
JK news - oh we all know what happened
with that do people still leave comments
on this [ __ ] - that video they
I know right do you know what like ever
since that came out a lot of people
tried sending me apologies like dude I
was so young like I didn't realize that
all the hateful things I was saying and
I was like look man you said what you
meant yeah that's fine you know like you
want me for like to forgive you for what
for having your own opinion about like
how you feel about me so like to me I
was just like I don't really know how to
respond to it because I don't think
there's really anything to respond to
and but that just goes to show too and
when I tell people this I don't think
people truly understand I said that
people who say things in the moment
people who say things on YouTube like
that that's such a harsh thought an
opinion about somebody what they see
through these random videos and they go
out their way to write long diatribe
about why they hate somebody or they're
usually really young
they're super young or they're [ __ ]
dumb old people so just let it be like
what's gonna happen and people are
allowed to have their opinions on things
but you know when we sit there and we
let these comments kind of eat us up
that's when we kind of lose right right
and it but it's not to say it's not hard
it's [ __ ] difficult sometimes because
sometimes you just want to find them and
[ __ ] them up right like I've had dreams
where I had a dream once where I heard
dream that is stem from this [ __ ]
video that I saw this guy Chester see do
okay and basically what happens is like
in the video he finds somebody who
leaves a bad comment it makes him delete
it right and in my dream I think I
watched that video and that that night
it had to be that because that was the
only thing I was I thought that video
was [ __ ] hilarious all right but I
had a dream literally that I found
somebody that could find where somebody
lives to their IP address
I found this [ __ ] person and it was
like some jackass like 18 year old kid
and I [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out of a
girl and it felt [ __ ] great and I was
I don't know when that when I had this
dream but it was like a few years ago
right so I'm like 18 I mean I'm still in
my 20s yeah I mean like I still [ __ ] you
up are you yes I beat the [ __ ] [ __ ]
at this eight-year-old in my dream and I
made them apologize and then in that
dream I met his parents apologize to me
for raising a piece of [ __ ] kid okay I
woke up with a [ __ ] boner because it
so powerful I was like I feel powerful
as [ __ ] because a [ __ ]
oh wow yeah but that's like how you
created your own fan in your own head
created the age and everything
- libbing [ __ ] [ __ ] out of a child I
felt great nice that I was 18 he's a
[ __ ] adult he knows better it's hard
because like I think sometimes we when
somebody does [ __ ] up things we always
tell them like oh it's because they're
young but then I I always wonder like
what's that what's the line that we get
to hold them accountable for the things
that they say exactly exactly I don't
really know like for me I feel like it
has to be I think everybody has to be
accountable to a certain extent even if
they're young and they [ __ ] up and
they're saying when they're young you
still have to be held accountable for
you at that age there's a lot more
forgiveness when you're younger but use
you still have to be accountable for
that [ __ ] right exactly so like I don't
know it was just really weird to receive
a lot of those apologies like oh I'm so
sorry I said mean things to you but I
don't mean it now and I'm like doesn't
matter yeah it doesn't matter so what
you should yeah exactly and it's like
and it's fine Oh an opinion yeah and you
know JK I think JK news is demographic
is a lot younger so it's like they're
still figuring themselves out they're
still figuring themselves out you kids
always say like a lot of dumb [ __ ] I
said a lot of dumb [ __ ] when I was that
age so I can't really hold that against
them because I expect people to forgive
me for the things I said when I was
younger right I say a lot of dumb [ __ ]
when I was younger man I still say dumb
[ __ ] now as an adult
that's why JK news was the best I said
all my opinions I feel like that's wrong
I'm like you're probably right it
probably is wrong really [ __ ] no I'm
just saying things or you would you guys
find it entertaining or not is really up
to you yeah I also find that you're
stubborn too I guess I can't be stubborn
but I'm just you know I'm stuck because
I'm stubborn about opinions because
there are dissipates
you know I think it's really odd when we
live in a space where people go what
people can't understand what something
is an opinion about stuff and if they're
if they feel like I'm wrong about it
that's okay too like I'm not mad at you
for thinking I'm wrong but your opinions
shape who you are as a person and how
you think and how you carry yourself so
like if it's something if a person
admires for who you are and then you
just say one thing that they completely
disagree with it's kind of like oh [ __ ]
I never knew that David was this kind of
person well you could go [ __ ] die for
all I care about
okay that's not mrs. Hammond I'm joking
obviously but if you're proof that's
that's the other thing other side of it
too right and this is something that
I've been you know I've only came to a
realization recently about why fandom
annoys me a lot right
kpop stands people who extremely loved
sports
yeah people who live and die by hobbies
and stuff like that like hardcore gamers
or whatever it's not that I dislike the
people if they have a habit in
themselves that I don't like about human
beings right which is when people who
can't say separate themselves from
something that's not reality
right so you set your identity into a
hobby versus investing into yourself is
that so they're their hobby becomes
their identity mm-hmm right yeah if BTS
is crying I'm crying if you're making
fun of BTS oh you're making fun of me
right right rather than saying oh it's
okay they don't like kpop they can think
it's whatever the word is [ __ ] dumb
stupid [ __ ]
whatever that is it's okay cuz they
don't have to like so well why do you
have to not like it they don't have to
like the [ __ ] that you like they can
think it's dumb stupid whatever negative
taboo word that they want to use call it
[ __ ] or whatever they go well why do
they have to say that why can't they
write that's true
yeah you know but what happens is that
people identify themselves in their
hobbies so much they think that it's
like oh you're saying that because you
don't understand what this is you don't
know what it does for me well now we're
talking about something different you're
you're mad at somebody for disliking
something that you like because it's
helped change your life that's cool it
did that for you it doesn't have to do
that for them and make us still think
that what you're doing is dumb just move
on from it that's why I don't like
fandom it's not so much k-pop fans or
whatever right cuz I listen to cream
music all the time
it's just anybody who kind of sets their
identity into something else I think
that to me is is sad right it's like oh
you're talking [ __ ] about the game or
community the game or community you're
not an oppressed group [ __ ] you know I
mean what I'm talking about you're like
trying to gain civil rights for what a
game or group like shut the [ __ ] up dude
same thing with people who are hardcore
like MMA fans I love MMA
but they're like or like when a sports
team wins they go we finally won we the
support made them present yes yeah
without the fans support the team would
not have any like good morale yeah yeah
and I think to us because I'm around a
group of people who don't really had
that right like we like sports right a
for example like we had I had a
conversation with you know a lot of a
couple of the guys that we trained with
and one of the guys is Nick in this guy
name is Alex I Alex is a [ __ ] Conor
McGregor hater
he thinks he's [ __ ] trash he's like
he's just hyped up he had a few great
fights with Eddie Alvin he had that one
fight where he knocked out Eddie kicked
Eddie Alvarez asses he asked and he
knocked out although and he goes well
what has he done since then and you know
that's his argument but you know and
Nick disagrees Nick's like no he is an
amazing fighter people have trouble with
his left hand they can't deal with how
he adapts like there's a lot of people
say they could do low kicks and and
they'll they'll take Connor McGregor out
and they haven't been able to you know
he did a great job against Habib even
though he the people say he got mauled
in the third round he looked really
great he was actually I was striking him
so they all had these disagreements but
nobody gets in their feelings it goes
[ __ ] you that's true you know to me that
sounds like a very adult and mature
converse exactly so a nice debate yeah
and it doesn't even have to be a debate
it's just more like these are my
opinions and these are my thoughts
so like Nick doesn't identify himself
with being a huge Conor McGregor fan he
doesn't go like you don't like Conor
maybe you clearly don't know MMA you're
[ __ ] dumb are you saying that I'm not
good like that's a type of fan of my
dislike right because now we're not
having a conversation about the things
we like now you're putting into your own
personal [ __ ] up issues because you
identify with this group that's a music
group or you identify with the sports
team that way or even sometimes it
happens like that with food right right
people get mad when they go I don't like
meeting me so what don't you like about
enemies maybe the person that's [ __ ]
like Vietnamese food let them not like
it or maybe show them something better
yeah yeah do you have any like hobbies
that you really like like that not to
that extreme no no I mean like I like I
like baking but that's my baking that
you guys are kind of talking about right
so
whenever I bake something I remember I
brought it in a fruit tart and I was
like Davey should try you're like nah
man I can't have it I was like and I ate
it for you you [ __ ]
hard my heart is sinking because I put
my whole heart and soul into it and you
just refuse me just like and I ate it
was delicious I I did eat it was very
delicious and I made him what you
Awful's - yeah you like that that was
good to you you make really good
desserts I think like that's your [ __ ]
like you like you like sweets like
that's your thing I love sweets I love
desserts and like I always like to try
out different kinds mmm
because I don't know one day one day I
would I want to like try a few recipes
out and see like if I can make something
out of it yeah and that's fun and I
think to like if we if we wanted to
bring an example of like like you really
like baked goods and desserts right
Richards [ __ ] Korean guy over here
and then you make this dessert right and
then I eat it let's say I eat it and I
hate it right right I tell you that I
hate it yeah right I think that's a
little different if people want to make
a comparison versus like fandom of music
sports or whatever because that's like
it's more like I put my heart and soul
into this so it sucks that this person
who I gave a piece of myself to did it
like it that I care about right versus
this other because you actually created
you had a hand in this right and the
reason why I don't understand it as well
I guess with like something like a music
group right no I totally get what you're
talking about
and I think for me it's just like I
wouldn't really be able to sort of
relate to that because I I don't go to
that extreme but I've seen it I've seen
people get offended on the things that
they like but that I don't like and I'm
just like okay chill yeah virtue hey you
know you you you live your life this is
what you like you you go do that you
know I don't you to be a part of it no I
make jokes about it all the time I don't
actually feel a certain way right and I
think like when I started to be like oh
they actually feel a certain way I
thought people sometimes when they don't
like kpop or something they go like I
don't understand why people like these
[ __ ] these [ __ ] you know cookie
cutter surgery face boys or something to
say some [ __ ] like that right like
that's the comment they just people go
off right like I understand somebody
goes what you don't like this
musics [ __ ] dope you know you could
disagree right right right
you couldn't get like passionate about
it but people are like how [ __ ] dare
you we are human beings too we're people
too we're people what are you talking
about now community David shut the [ __ ]
up how about that community it's the
camaraderie that they have that shared
hobby I mean let me tell you that guys
this right these people don't give an
actual [ __ ] about you how about that
they don't they really don't so they
only care about you if you only care
about the same things they care about I
guess so I see I guess they don't maybe
some of that maybe some of these like
basketball players or whatever they care
about you a lot if you that makes you
feel better but if you could take
yourself away and just really enjoy the
hobby and have the phantom dress in the
clothes put the makeup and the glitter
on your face or whatever and enjoy it
like that cool but a lot of people not
also not to like your hobby and there
will be people who don't like your stuff
and you have to be okay with that too
because at the end of the day them not
liking what you like doesn't oppress you
doesn't take away any civil rights from
you doesn't do anything like that so
what if you really care about that
person's opinion who cares this podcast
is brought to you by purple my friends
purple mattress dun bless my body up so
good I've never slept so well in my life
that is a power that is a power of a
purple Manchester yes purple mattresses
have been or one of the biggest
blessings in my life because I was
sleeping on a crap box before a huge
crap box and I had no idea how important
sleep was to me I had no idea how much
back comfort was to me when it came to
sleeping and the purple mattress
approved everything that I thought wrong
I thought I needed to sleep on a slab of
rock in order to sleep better because I
was told that by old ancient Asian
people and guess what
it's different it's not for me I need a
mattress that feels right for me that
keeps me cool at night and has actual
rocket scientists developed the material
behind it and that's a purple mattress
baby
so my friends a hundred night risk-free
trial if you're not fully satisfied you
can return your mattress for a full
refund backed by a ten year warranty
free shipping and returns you're going
to love purple and right now my
listeners will get a free purple pillow
with the purchase of a mattress that's
in addition to the great gifts they're
offering
site-wide just explain to 84-88 the only
way to get this repeal oh it's a text
brain to 8 4 - 8 8 8
that's BR a I n 2 8 4 8 8 8 message and
data rates may apply if you if you
straight-up told me yo Julia baking is
stupid right I mean obviously I don't
feel it but like what if I'm just like
David I really care about you as a
person how dare you say something about
that to me I'll be like what the hell's
wrong with you
I don't like baking all right it's great
your stuff tastes good but I don't like
begging boban then you will never make
me anything ever again no never again
that's exactly what happened some same
but you know but that's also based on
like you and I having a personal
relationship right of course people who
like these hobbies don't have a personal
relationship with anything that's true
legit I think last time I don't know if
I made the cut last time but we were
talking about new cars and there's a car
that was interested in which is the
hyundai ioniq you totally [ __ ] it on me
for that and I was like [ __ ] you David
like yeah I mean yeah no yeah you you
you offended me yeah that's a great
example you offended me on that and I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
because this car I like this car for XYZ
reasons exactly she got it anyways yeah
it was the best choice I ever made do I
love my car that's what I'm saying it's
in the color that I want and the trim
the trim level like it they had three
different kinds they had the base one
the middle one and the top one the top
one would have been nice if I knew that
it was a lot harder to get it in the
color blue so like I was totally cool
with the middle trim and like oh my god
David David I got like 50 to 53 miles
per gallon man and I also get electric
miles yeah see she's super hyped about
her choices and I'm really glad that she
got it but as you could see even though
we disagreed about something that she
really really liked he called it a [ __ ]
car I did not say [ __ ] car is it look
like [ __ ] that's different it's
completely different it's a great great
hybrid car yeah especially because it's
a plug-in hybrid which I love plug-in
hybrids the vehicle that I was actually
waiting for before I got my new car was
actually the Prius prime I mean that the
previous prime the Rav
for prime is [ __ ] s 300 horsepower it
goes like zero to 60 in like five or six
seconds and there's some mini sized SUV
and I was thinking about it getting that
car and it's also a plug-in hybrid but
it looks way better than yours but look
see that and then that's the thing I'm
saying it's like you liked something I
didn't like it however you got it you're
happy with it and I'm happy for you yeah
that's all that it is and we still hang
out all the yeah and you know you know
like despite him trying to change my
mind
I still stood my ground he was literally
trying to convince me it's like yeah but
there's so many other great cars out
there than the than the ioniq I'm like
yeah but that's the one I like David
it's the ones the one you should get
yeah and that's what he said that's the
one you should get but legit though
trying to get that car was just so
frustrating that aftermath of it okay so
so I've been looking since like last
year right and I didn't get this car
until April and I've been looking at all
the official like Hyundai websites this
he's like hey where's this car where's
this car specifically plug-in because
they come in all electric and they also
come in as just a regular hybrid and I
was trying to look for the plug-in in
blue with the trim that I wanted right
and it was just so hard to find because
every time they came in with a new
shipment it would just go within a week
yeah like that's how fast it was and
like I think people were just trying to
get it in time before like the the
rebate budget would like change right
and so because it was like 7,500 versus
like exactly and um so I found the car
and surprisingly it was through CarGurus
actually like it wasn't even on any
hyundai official website I was like oh
that's very interesting
oh my gosh the clunker yeah yeah but
like it was just like it was sitting on
the slot for a while and it wasn't used
or anything knows knew but then like I
feel like CarGurus was pretty much
updated with like what the official
website inventory is yeah and it wasn't
even on - official website so I was like
oh that's interesting like but the car
is here and I'm sent a message to them
and they're like hey do you have this
car available on your lot and you're
like yeah we still have it you can come
by and test drive it and I was like holy
Pete I'm so excited my blue car is here
right and so like I was it was really
hard for it and I think like these go
for like MSRP is like about 3500 or
something and I was able to get it
awesome yeah oh yeah sorry
35000 yeah and i was able to get it at
32,000 out the door that's pretty good
yeah it was pretty good my boyfriend's
mom helped me kind of negotiate them for
that yeah and so they're like cool
you're the new owner of this car I'm
like fantastic great right and I decided
to purchase it because I felt like this
is going to be something long-term and
and it it just felt like home so I
didn't feel like there was any other car
that I would be necessarily interested
in yeah yeah and so you know how they
tell you is like okay so here's your
temporary license plate in about three
months or give it the DMV 90 days for
you to send her plates right about two
weeks before the 90 days were up I was
just like I haven't even received my
plates and during that time of those
three months my boyfriend's mom got a
like she'd leased the car and she got
her plates in already within that time
and I was like what the hell like where
are my plates right and so the plates
end up kind of expiring my temporary
place time expiring I called the
dealership and I know sorry I called the
DMV first and the divi was like huh
strange it says that there was nothing
submitted for your car and I was like
what so then I call the DMV and the Dean
he's like yeah it seems like we
submitted the paperwork but we're not
quite sure what's happening let me call
you back right after a week nothing
right and I was like what the hell is in
like after another week cause why I'm
like all right [ __ ] it I'm gonna call
them again right and be like because
I've been trying to text somebody and
and they're like oh yeah you know we're
trying to figure it out we're trying to
get in touch the DMV lady because I
guess like she only comes like once
every two weeks or so whatever to like
file all their paperwork and so so I was
like okay fine that's fine right like
just keep me updated but nobody was
keeping me updated on any of these
things and I get it you know they're
busy with day to day trying to make
sales and whatnot but it was just like
come on dude this is an issue you have a
customer that do not have their plates
and their temporary license plate has
expired
yeah what is that gonna [ __ ] say
about your dealership yeah right and so
I get a um I get a hold of the DMV lady
and she told me the updation is like so
looks like somebody registered this car
and I was like what yeah and then she
was like yeah um somebody registers car
and it's on a guy named Matt and I was
like what the [ __ ] like [ __ ] is Matt and
you're like yeah like we're not quite
sure because like so I guess like the
dealership was fairly new
and they bought it off from a previous
dealership and so in that previous
dealership they probably made a deal
with this guy named Matt who was
interested in a car of that or something
similar of it and whoever the sales guy
is accidentally wrote the wrong VIN
number yeah however you accidentally
write it right and then like filed it
and like they had like he has a pink
slip for it and whatnot right and so she
was like yeah we've been trying to get
ahold of this guy named Matt - I'm
signing off the rights and permissions
that he'd never driven it off the law
and he doesn't own this car right and I
was like how did this even happen you
like am I even the first-time owner
because there's a lot of benefits to
being a first-time owner for that car
yeah and I was like am I even the
first-time owner or is this guy named
Matt gonna be on this thing and she's
like rest assured you're the first time
I was like am I you know and then at
this point like I was already pretty
frustrated because I was being ghosted
by several different managers to try to
help me out with the situation and she
was like the first one to call and kind
of like help me out about it right but
then I was just like I was so out of
words I was like okay so this guy named
Matt apparently is registered to this
car so what kind of like how long have
you guys found out and then they're like
well we found out 60 days in after you
purchased the car and I was like and you
couldn't have told me what's up yeah you
know like if you had communicated with
me that hey this is an issue but we're
working on it let's a reassign you some
new temporary plates so you don't have
to worry about it I would have been fine
but the fact that they found out 60 days
within of me purchasing the car and me
waiting for my plates they're just like
oh we're just now working on it to try
to find that you know what I'm like no
that's [ __ ] like I I don't believe
in the coincidence that oh I just so
happen to call you guys and you guys
just so happen to start working on it I
was like no no you know like you guys
probably forgot about it and once I
started screaming at you guys you guys
started working on it and so she was
like yeah we're trying to get a hold of
him and I was like okay fine right
and so like months go by like literally
like months and and I'm trying to figure
out an update of site okay so am I gonna
get a temporary permit can when can I
get a temporary permit because my
current permits are expired do I need to
rent a car like what do I need to do
because pretty much I'm driving this car
illegally yeah right and then they're
like oh justjust wait a week just wait a
week your temporary permit is gonna come
in and then again another two weeks
like like I check up with them like very
like weekly and like they're like oh
yeah just wait till next week just wait
until next week and then two weeks after
the whole thing is when I got a
temporary permit and that since I got a
temporary permit I was like asking the
guy was like hey so I was asking this
manager who started to like who actually
came on and helped me out on this
because again there are several managers
that decide to ghost me and like every
time I call the dealership else I can't
kind of speak to a manager like oh hold
on please
they'll forward me to a sales guy and
I'm like are you a manager door like no
like I speak to manager sure to put me
on hold and then they hang up on me and
like it happened several times and I was
like look I'm not trying to get money
out of you guys what's really
frustrating is that I just genuinely
need help and I need an update and I
need to know what's going on but the
fact that you guys keep ignoring me
doesn't help the fact and now I'm angry
yeah now I'm angry like you you took
someone who is very calm so one who was
very reasonable who was very patient and
waiting for your call now you made me
angry yeah and so literally five months
yeah oh my god it was like five months
but anyways so I got the temporary
permit right and this manager was like
super helpful he was like really helping
me out he was like yeah I'm so sorry
like this is something that like rarely
happens and like we're not quite sure
like why why this hiccup happened but
we're working hard on getting it right
like like finance department everybody
in this whole dealership had no idea how
this happened right and I was like it's
fine just I just need to know when my
plates are gonna come in right and then
he handed me over my temporary permits
and I was like so is it like on the way
is our things being processed and he was
like well they wouldn't have given like
giving me this permit if it wasn't and I
was like cool and so so then I go
outside with him so I can tape on my
temporary permit and I was like look man
like you know all of this frustration
like absolutely was not worth it like
all this worry and frustration and it
was just like this anxiety of like where
are my plates can I still get my rebates
and my still first-time owner like none
of all those thoughts like were worth it
because I remember when I purchased this
car I was like cool after I signed my my
name on these papers do you need
anything else for me there
nope we'll take care of everything else
for you send the papers to DMV and then
this car should be yours and bada-bing
bada-boom right none of that right and I
told was like you guys provided me a
service that I didn't have to worry
about all I had to do was sign the
papers and be happy with this car but
all he was left with just a stress and
frustration yeah and so the guy was like
so then I told him was like so what can
you do for me yeah
what can you do Yeah right and then so
the guy was like I can get you free gas
and I was like I already got gas what
else yeah and then he was like I how
about like an oil change maybe we can
get you all a change like a maybe like a
car detail or something and I was like
okay that's a little better and then he
was like okay will you tape on this
permit and then I'll go inside and write
that up for you right and I was like
okay cool right and at this point I was
like damn dude like I never felt like
I've ever stood up for myself until that
moment right yeah and so then I tape it
with the permit and I walk in and he
prints out this little sheet and he was
like okay so right here I have one free
oil change one car detail and a tire
rotation right and then I was like cool
make that two yeah I think I was like
and I was like I'll be a happy camper
and make it two
yeah and then he was like okay and so he
retype sit and he makes it two and then
he was like so you have two free oil
changes car detailed and tire rotations
and I was like great and about that free
gas and he was like everybody knows who
you are in this dealership every time
you come here you can't get free gas I
was like perfect that's great yeah and I
was like after that I was like like the
inside Julia like oh my god did you
actually pull that [ __ ] off as I go
because normally I would never be able
to have the [ __ ] guts to do that [ __ ]
but I think I was just so pissed that
was like I need something from this
because none of this was worth it yeah
none of this was worth it and I was like
to to be ignored and to not be
acknowledged and then to just be strung
along for five months after the fact so
it literally took me eight months to get
my plates did it feel good after you won
[ __ ] yeah I should took so long that's
[ __ ] sucks
if it's it [ __ ] sucks even when I got
my car right like
I'm at least this forerunner and at
least it it's like a forerunner ventured
you know got a whole all the whole
shebang on it right it's like 50 K right
which is by the way half the price of
what my Tesla was so those like makes me
happy right now for the lease the price
that I got I could have got way cheaper
but the problem with that is I would
have to stay at that dealership and
haggle with them right but you know I
traded in the car put like very minimal
money down on it and then I'm paying
like 740 a month or something like that
right for a 50k car definitely I
could've got that down to like six
seventy or 640 or something they may be
like $80 less but the problem with that
is I sit there and they'll do the thing
when they go I can't do my manager man
what's the number that I come like bro
because they first gave me a ridiculous
number right and I'm like clearly that's
not the right number do you're [ __ ]
lying to me in my head and I'm like well
this is the number that I want to pay I
want to pay seven fifteen right and he
goes well I don't know if I could do
that I was like come on I think you can
do it I just want to go home like give
it to me yeah I mean and I was like and
that's but that by the way it's a great
deal for them because I could get it for
somewhere else for like 600 something
right but then you know $50 seven $80 to
me is really not much money so I don't
really care I just needed to get the car
and get out but the guy was like it's so
funny cuz they always have like these
car salesman tactics cuz he goes on the
on the foreign adventure I do my
research on the car before he goes well
let me see if I could get that that rack
if you walk away that too I was like of
course I can because that venture comes
with the rack so I know that it comes
with it he's just trying to pull all
these things back I mean he goes oh I
don't think it sounds like bro that's
the reason why it's called the venture
because it's ready for rock climbing and
the rack is there that's why it's on
there you're not giving it to me for
free I mean but it's like he's just
sitting there and just like I told us
like look I'm an easy customer I'm not
broke out of my mind I don't need a
haggle and that extra fifty or eighty
dollars like I can get this down lower
or I can go somewhere else just give it
to me for this price I was like didn't
like what 750 whatever 750 or whatever
740 or whatever just give to me for this
price and then we'll walk out he goes I
don't know if I was like you can do it
just go back get it done so I could walk
out here yeah that was out there like an
hour I was like well it's because it's
gonna take what another like six hours
of my life to get it for $70 less than
month I know that's a lot to other
people but the nice attacks right off
for me yeah and then like for me it's
just not worth the time
and so I'm just like I whatever just
give it to me right cuz I'm pretty sure
somebody else would have taken it for
that from like 680 to 750 I'm like
whatever this is it's nominal just give
it to me dude so I just walked out with
it like that because I bought a car a
couple of times like I know what it
takes to get the lower price right but
then I went at the walk out come back
three days later come back for another
bike here here's the car I'm like I
don't got time for this to save 70 bucks
a month like [ __ ] it just give it to me
Yeah right I'll just I'll just deal with
it I'll go I don't know I'll go suck
some dick I'll make more money I'll
figure it out car dealerships are hard
to deal with that's why I like people
like Tesla Tesla there's no tackling
right you you know what the price is you
walk with that there's no haggling
that's the price you order it and you
get your car right yeah but the
dealerships are like that dude it's just
it's just so different for me because I
just felt like it wasn't a very normal
circumstance it was just like a freak
accident and I just felt like for
someone who was involved in something of
a freak accident why why isn't anyone
trying to help me figure it out and then
they're like oh you know but we are
trying to figure it out but we don't
want to like tell you an answer quite
yet because like we're not sure yet and
I was like I don't care just give me an
update of like hey any updates on this
like no we're still waiting cool you
know versus like leave me in the dark
for like one to two weeks and then just
be like oh yeah yeah we're still trying
to figure it out I'm like no yeah you
forgot yeah and if I don't [ __ ] give
you constant reminders you're gonna keep
forgetting yeah and so they sent the
plates over to the dealership because if
the DMV sent I don't know whatever
[ __ ] if they sent it over to my
house is gonna take a lot longer right
so they expedited it over to dealership
I go to the dealership and then okay
yeah well we'll put the license plates
on and then like here's here's all your
paperwork like everything's pretty much
settled and I was like cool so the car
is mine and really guess you are the you
are the first time owner of this car
like this is this is all yours and I was
like finally thank you so much for
helping me now can I get that free gas
yeah and then the manager was like I
don't think you told me that every time
I come to this dealership and everybody
knows here who I am that I will get free
gas any time I come here and then he was
like yeah can I get a cash card someone
and then like they just feel
from your mic thank you yeah because I
just want to see if they're actually
gonna stick to their word did so yeah
don't let anyone take advantage of you
on this [ __ ] so this it was like the
first time you really kind of stuck
people like sticking up for yourself
yeah that must have felt good it was so
good David cuz I was like I never knew I
had it in me and like I never really
practiced it very much but then
everybody around me was like wow you did
that I was like [ __ ] yeah I did and
they're like that's so funny cuz like
I'm so lazy now like I don't do that
[ __ ] anymore I'm just like how we're
gonna figure this [ __ ] out
cuz I think like sometimes - like I get
overzealous with that [ __ ] and that's
why even at that dealership like I could
have sat there at the [ __ ] up bro just
give me the [ __ ] car for six 680 or
650 or whatever you know but then it's
like I'm so I'm like whatever dude so
just just let me walk out of here right
now
yeah no I'm thinking about it and maybe
I should just got it for 680 din I mean
you should oh I would say you should've
I mean you would have definitely saved a
couple of dollars oh it's a bribe us
like five [ __ ] days though out of my
life it's like do I really want to lose
five [ __ ] days out of my life cuz I
have to go out
go find other prices tell them like well
this place is gonna give it to me for
this also that the the 4runner that I
got there's not a lot of them so if
somebody comes and they take it then I
have to wait for another one right
because the 400 venture right now
there's not too many in the area there's
like maybe four or five and there's the
only one I wanted was silver so there
was a black one that was available I
don't want an all black all that car
because I had an all black car before
because it's they have as black trim on
it so you wouldn't be able to see the
contrast so I was like [ __ ] it I don't
want that one and this one also had like
the sunroof in the upgraded suspension
so I was like okay whatever just give
this one to me well I don't know I mean
I feel like that's a little bit more
straightforward I feel like I was more
in the dark because a guy named Matt
apparently owns this car that in your
situation [ __ ] sucked
yeah I was like what's happening here
that was pretty [ __ ] terrible I hate
[ __ ] like that dude yeah it's hard to
sometimes like when you know when I
think to like the biggest issue with
that is the reason why it's frustrating
is just it's not so much that the thing
that happened it's more that you were
just kind of being pushed aside and
ignored and this I hope with hopefully
you'll go away or something its hold on
like I need this [ __ ] where the [ __ ] is
this thing at you know exactly and I've
have receipts and like I've had a
history where
like I am patiently waiting like I
literally give them like a week to two
weeks to try to get back to me on their
own time and then like once a third week
hits I'm like yeah yes it's too long
yeah it's just too much well look at you
Thanks I stood up for myself David you
think before you wouldn't have never
done that I don't think so I think I've
been like oh okay I guess like they are
doing whatever they could but then I
just had a feeling that they were
religious ignoring me though yeah
because every time I called they're like
oh what is the situation about and I was
like
bull-fucking-shit every note everyone
knows my [ __ ] ass problem you know
because they're like oh yeah what we're
like oh let me look into it yeah I
promise I'll call you back and then they
never call me back
so to me I'm like that is just very
shitty customer service yeah yeah
because like I'm not asking for much I'm
just asking what is going on with my car
yeah that's all I'm asking I'm not
saying hey give me money because you
guys [ __ ] up it's more of like she'd
been like you know the [ __ ] I am and
Julia Child
no I following I'm gonna put you guys on
[ __ ] blast right now but Hyundai
[ __ ] Rowland Heights you stupid sons
about on over there yeah I mean like
I've thought about it I've sincerely
thought about it but also the State
House like that's just too much hate to
hold on to like I don't know if I can I
can't wear the app you know where that
[ __ ] business is that yeah yeah
but that sucks though and this sometimes
hard like I think when I'm when you're
like in a customer service like area and
you don't get that service it's very
difficult right it's a second god dude
like especially because you know
sometimes people say stuff like well you
don't know what it's like to be on this
side so you I worked a customer service
yeah same
I [ __ ] sold tuxedos to some of the
most grouchy grumpy human [ __ ] beings
on earth
and the only time I've ever said
something bad to somebody that they
[ __ ] were yelling at me or cursing at
me for some [ __ ] that was out of my
control and I tried my best and then I
would get a little pissed but other than
that like I would never ignore
somebody's problem yeah I mean I would
try to make sure I would follow up if
there were any issues but a lot of
people just don't do that yeah yeah cuz
I'm nervous is a hard job man have you
worked in have you worked in what did
you work at before JK stuff I worked at
a restaurant yeah oh that's right you
want the steak house for a bunch of
Korean people right
and must be difficult it was quite
difficult it was quite difficult but
there was a time where I wasn't working
for them because I wanted to focus on my
portfolio in college and I just remember
my managers like no no no no no no
please stay please stay like me I need
you at least like I need you for the
weekend Saturday like Friday and
Saturday I need you Friday and Saturday
and I was like I can't like my project
like these projects take a long time
yeah you know cuz if each class is three
hours and you go to the class like two
times a day that's six hours a week
right so imagine like how much more time
you need to spend onto your project in
your homework right so I was like oh no
I I kind of need that time and this is
like just one day I just need you for
one day and I'm like no I just need you
for Saturday just come Saturday I'm like
I don't know mrs. Kim and she was like
I'll make you do pokey every time you
come and like sold it's like I will do
Fordo pokey and coming one time I think
that's so [ __ ] funny yeah I do is she
bribed me with food she knew you got
that once a week yeah once a week every
single talking hilarious dude out of all
the things you'd even ask for more pay
you just got paid food yeah I wanted the
pokey you're so [ __ ] funny why did
you ask for more money I don't know
cuz I'm dumb David I've been like yeah I
can but then like I don't know like I
think I need to get paid an extra couple
bucks an hour see julia was dumb then
okay all Julia wanted was just food oh
my god so you worked there one day a
week yeah I worked in one day a week as
a cashier yeah and then eventually I was
moved up to a waitress well I was really
excited because like I really wanted to
be a busser because I kind of like doing
physical work and so like I would every
time I would see the man she's like hey
put me as a busser put me as a busser
man you need any more holiday people put
me as a busser
like so so can do cashier I could be a
busser I could be a good buster right
and so they gave me a shot and they put
me on Buster and it was like the funnest
time I've ever had and then later a
manager came up to me and was like hey I
need you to be a waitress and I was like
what it's like I'm living my bus or
dreams oh my god dude
you have such low dream hilarious and
then he was like yeah but you know
you've been working here for a while and
there's other people here
that want to become like a waiter but I
don't think like they're suitable for
the job or I think you know they're a
little too new and people who have
seniority kind of feel entitled to being
like a waiter and I was like aha
and I was like yeah so give it to them
you know they want it and they're like
yeah but you know everybody gets along
with you and you've been here for a
while and people respect you so like if
you move up you know because you're from
a cashier to to a busboy if you move up
from bus by - waitress like no one's
gonna give me [ __ ] for it and I was like
what but what brought about my bus are
dreams
oh and he was like please please and I
was like okay I guess I'll do for you
and so like I became a waitress and then
people had like nothing else to say
there's no [ __ ] to be said they're being
nice to me in one eye and I was like I
guess it was cool because I did get an
opportunity I'm learning how to be a
waitress and yeah what the protocol is
and that's fine too and I made more
money so in the end it worked out but I
don't know I feel like I don't know I
really enjoyed bussing I really enjoyed
bussing David that's weird
[ __ ] I bet you'd even ask for more money
if you did become a waitress did you
well I mean he told me that it would be
more pay yeah but you'd been like what
type of pay and then you should have
been like that's not enough like I
enjoyed businger that's my [ __ ] I mean
if you want I guess if you do for this
price yeah yeah no no no I was very I
was very still in that bubble cuz I I
never really know goshi anything and
that point in my life
yeah I mean I'm kind of like that too
though like I hate negotiating is so
annoying
that's why I usually do things over the
phone but you know my car was dying so I
was like I need to get a car today I had
to get a car it's a very nice car I mean
I also couldn't like drive in my drive
to San Diego to see my brother or
something like that or if I wanted to go
on trips I couldn't do that either so it
was just like that car was holding me
back something like the other day it so
damn David you know what you should have
just called me out because I still got a
Corolla around yeah that cool all right
hey hey it would have done you enough it
in a Corolla not time for you to get the
car of your dreams David I don't fit in
a coral enjoying all right it's just too
small and then I it's funny cuz like I
did you used to drive
krohler was a camera light a Camry how's
the smallest car I've ever had wasn't
company yeah it's pretty big that you're
specifically the Camry was huge yeah but
just recently - so I was at so Tim and I
went to go eat dinner yeah or or lunch
I'm sorry at this Japanese restaurant
out in torrents they asked us to come do
some social media stuff so we did Makar
dies right battery the battery craps out
and so I had to get jumped but the
[ __ ] funny thing was so Tim and I you
know we don't know much about cars we're
not really handy dude what's right but I
do know how to jump a car that's like my
[ __ ] that's why I had jumper cables in
my car because my battery has died
multiple times before and I just replace
it's better not to long ago so I don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on but I
think what happened was Tim [ __ ]
jumped out and scared me why was parking
my car so I left the lights on so but my
and so and I was blasting music so when
I came out I didn't really hear the
beeping letting me know that the lights
are on but you know with these I had a
newer car before so I didn't need to
worry about that you just had it on an
auto setting and the lights turned off
by itself so I came out the car we were
[ __ ] around joking around whatever
whatnot had a great great lunch come
back cars [ __ ] dead in this parking
lot pissed off I'm like [ __ ] because
just the night before I was at Barton
Barton Gio's house watching the fight
and then my car died at their house and
so so apparently with my car I don't
know what the issue is but if it gets if
it gets if the weather goes like below
50 degrees my car won't start
hmm just [ __ ] and I was like this car is
so [ __ ] old if it's below 50 degrees
the car just won't work and so by the
grace of God like 15 minutes later after
trying to start at like a gajillion
times it finally started yeah and so
even it probably warmed up exactly and
then in the morning after that I was a
math after that it was the the Monday
guy was gonna go train apparently was
too cold in the morning I couldn't start
my car I was like [ __ ] this car at this
point right because I've put so much
money into fixing it but at the at the
at the parking lot luckily enough so Tim
had his car he didn't leave yet but
apparently in these new cars the battery
of a car is actually in the trunk of it
Oh interesting
yeah so in like if you get an Audi a4
like the new ones the the battery
doesn't [ __ ] work it's not in the
front it's in the trunk and so we tried
but like that it didn't work but do you
know what girl names soy yes
so she's it's cool she's the food right
she's she's another blue hair sister out
there yeah I don't think she has blue
anymore you suck so nice Wow
but she you're so you're attacking us
David the blue hair people yes and you
can all go die [ __ ]
so we she was there yeah luckily and
it's so funny
sorry too she goes I could help you jump
your car I was like cool she goes David
I don't only think about cars how do I
open the hood so she just know anything
about cars like you know pop the hood I
said up she goes okay what do I do is I
get turn on the car and then gas a
little bit and I jump my car and thank
God I was out but that was like my last
straw I was like I fix his car so many
[ __ ] times it's left me stranded I
want to go camping I can't go can't be
in this car because I think I'm gonna
die if I take it so I finally just gave
it up and now and I was hard for me
because I love that car dude I love that
car since I I wanted that car since like
late high school early early college I
loved Honda elements I remember so many
people in JK were giving you [ __ ] yeah
they were [ __ ] taking naps in that
[ __ ] but it was so strange because you
had a Tesla and then all of a sudden you
get into Honda even now like I got this
4runner yeah I hate pain like 700 bucks
for it you know a month just because I
don't like spending money like that it's
not my thing but I had to think about a
couple of things the reason why I got
the car number one it's not gonna break
down
number two Toyota's are really reliable
yes number three it's very safe also on
top of that to like when my parents come
to town or you know if we all want to
carpool I can't I can never help out cuz
my Honda Element was a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] and the back seats were super
uncomfortable and I think people are
scared they're gonna die in my car so
nobody wanted to drive my car which was
kind of cool I don't I don't have to be
the one driving but then when my parents
come to town I feel bad that they're in
this shitty-ass car or like for Muriel's
parents too so I was like okay it's time
to upgrade and it's not like I can't
afford it you know so I might as well
just get something nice and then use it
for a long time I mean how long is your
lease on that car and are you the type
of person that just prefers to lease
over purchasing I'm at least this one
because I don't know if I want to keep
it but if I do I mean obviously you know
if you finance it it'll be better over
long - it'll be cheaper but if I lease
it at least it gives me
option to keep it or not because I don't
know if I want to go full electric later
so if I like the card it's great then I
might keep it around and then just
finance and then get a truck or if I
just don't like it at all
I'm sorry this waste is too much gas and
they have better SUV electric options
then I'm just gonna return the lease let
me just get a you know you know I hear
that Hyundai is coming out with some
SUVs that are all that's cool love it I
honestly I love it
legit like I sat in it like I tried out
so many other different cars you know I
tried out the Honda Civic which which
wasn't bad I just hated I don't know
maybe I'm too old school but I kind of
liked the analogue buttons of like
turning the volume or totally but I just
hate how they have this new touchscreen
feature where you just gotta like tap on
it you have it on your wheel - I think
yeah I know I think that's why people
have been okay with it cuz you have the
wheel turn thing but that's why I like
the 4runner as well I they have like
these good hard buttons like for like
for example this is the one hard thing
for me right it's climate controlled at
the touch through a screen yeah I prefer
a knob where I could just go like yes
yes yeah I mean yeah so that's why I
went for the 4runner because I was gonna
go for a Jeep Grand Cherokee which was a
car I had before but everything has to
be done to the screen the the Toyota has
all these analogue buttons and I love it
I like analog I like it a lot so like
the clarity was cool it was a nice Drive
like I love the feel of it and and but I
just didn't like the touch of volume
button and I'm like hmm that's like
original knobs on the clarity no no no
that was the Civic clarity all clarity I
have a different I have a different
opinion about that clarity I don't like
at all I feel like it's pretty hard it's
it's a big car but I don't like the
functionality of it because if you open
the trunk they there's this weird square
box that's just bright in the middle of
it and you can't move it or anything and
it's just basically where the battery is
the battery is back there so you you
compromise your trunk space but then
they give you a front and I'm like I
don't want to [ __ ] frunk I want a
full-on functioning truck also that car
is probably one of the ugliest things
I've ever seen in my life yeah I didn't
like
like a Ferrari yeah I didn't like the
color choices and then they had this
beam in the back that serve no function
like it didn't move with anything it
just stayed there and I'm like I don't
even know why it's here and I don't know
if it's like for support but either way
didn't like the clarity Civic was decent
the fit I felt like I was probably gonna
die in it just a small small it was
light but I mean I love the
functionality of it you probably would
have liked the hrb in the Honda HRV yeah
but I didn't want that big of a car
though yeah I didn't want that big of a
car and then if he's not that big though
it's tiny
it was way tire and then a CRV I don't
know it's it's it's kind of like a
crossover right well no like it's calm
if it's really small though that's why I
didn't get it was too small for me just
[ __ ] yeah for you but for me I feel
like it's no it's roughly about the same
size as your car just a little higher
oh really yeah I don't know I but it
doesn't get 52 miles per gallon though
yeah see I so the categories I wanted in
my car is that I wanted it a hybrid and
then if it was a plug-in hybrid that's
even better now I know like people are
probably gonna be asking me like oh why
not a Prius look maybe my ego is a
little too big on this but I did not
want to be associate with Prius drivers
I'm really sorry guys guys you guys are
like terrible drivers it's okay if they
are they could just run into my form I
told them all I mean like I think
curious is our great car great car
[ __ ] love it I love I love everything
about it I just don't like the drivers
in it and like I think for me is like I
don't want to be associated with that
I'm sorry man I'm sorry how dare you how
oppressed Prius drivers are they are a
group that needs to be hurt the fact
that you even [ __ ] said that I you
know what you know what it's all about
the [ __ ] ionics because you know why
they're the Korean version of the Prius
oh my god Prius hater dude how dare you
oppress the Prius driving group out
there they should [ __ ] kill you for
that [ __ ] look Prius is a great car I
just I I mean there I met a lot of Prius
drivers that are really cool but it's
just the ones that I meet on the road I
don't get it man I don't get it I don't
like them like maybe they just don't
like ionic drivers dude how about that
but you know what you know what who-who
else drives two very similarly to people
who drive Priuses or BMW drivers that's
what everybody says yeah I do think you
just because there's a lot of Prius impe
w.zahn here that's why she might be a
ratio thing it could be
I Drive slow in my [ __ ] for right now
because I'm afraid I'm gonna kill
somebody at that thing pretty big you're
pretty like high up there yeah and so
I'm looking at I'm scared for other
people on the road like my Honda Element
I think you a [ __ ] I would ride fast in
that [ __ ]
oh just whatever with it cuz I didn't
care about it yeah this thing is so
sturdy and big I'm scared people always
drive around me now yeah as I drove
faster my Honda Element and people were
just you even today you could just see
people around me like look at this [ __ ]
this eighty year old Asian guy and I
mean listen I could kill you if I wanted
to in this car yeah quiet you know I
feel I think I get frustrated when I see
trucks like pickup trucks on the road
and and I get why they leave so much
space in front of them is because like
they're a bigger car they weigh heavier
so like it takes longer for them to run
hundred percent you know like and I
understand that I understand that but I
think like before when my brain couldn't
understand it I'm like why why have so
much space in front of you why because
Julia you need to be a car length away
from other cars you [ __ ] tailgating
yeah but they're just like five car
lengths away and I'm like I don't get it
you probably drive like a [ __ ] maniac
dude very yeah so [ __ ] funny one time
she was driving me around huh and then
like she was just like oh shoot tonight
I missed his turn and like I just
remember like she would she'd break
really hard and she like speaking Korean
to herself I'm like what what just
happen wait was he supposed to go there
and I was like that's what I go through
every day and I am so scared I love her
that's why she has never allowed a drive
you better invite me to your wedding
mm-hm come through you better invite me
to your wedding because I witnessed the
beginning you should I mean here's
that's the funny thing two girls now
we're working on the wedding list it's
like it depends on who gets invited only
because of how small I think that Mariel
wants their wedding to be right so I
think like the one that everybody has to
be invited to is they're gonna be in the
party because I decide who wants go to
the boring one who wants to go to the
fun one the boring one is mainly gonna
be old people so I was like mm I think
everybody's gonna get invite to the
party one instead because I think for
her she wants to do it really really
small and then I want to have a fun
party so everybody probably everybody in
JK that you're gonna have to go to the
party one cuz you're not gonna want to
come to the one
that's just getting boring his [ __ ] as
long as I'm a part of it somehow I'm
cool oh you will be
it's gonna be super fun and we're not
don't pass food because I think that for
the food we're not gonna have
professional food is gonna be catered
food like like [ __ ] burgers tacos and
all that [ __ ] I know that that's how I
want it yeah
how does Muriel think about that she
wants that like she wants it she wants
she wants everything to be inexpensive
which I love because I don't want to
spend but either way no matter how
inexpensive it is it's gonna cost a
forty fifty grand
yeah I mean which I this was so
apprehensive of buying the car but it's
like I could have got a cheaper car but
at the same time it's like well I might
as well just have something that I like
and then and I'm not spending much on
gas cause I really don't go anywhere
except for like I'm gonna take the the
formula to go camping and stuff and
that's what I'm gonna spend yes well you
know the the Corolla that I have you
know they all gotta have your [ __ ]
Corolla dude your Corolla is falling
apart oh my god I mean physically it was
falling apart
but internally it was totally cool oh
yes yeah well guys that wraps up this
episode of the genius brain podcast you
got to hear Julia standing up for
herself for the first time over some
license plates may not seem like a big
deal you bits a big [ __ ] deal it is a
big deal to me and also no dealership is
gonna push me around that's right
[ __ ] Korean [ __ ] you Hyundai
ki KI she bought nobody she too is a she
by money anyways what can they find you
you can find me on instagram at X blue
apples with a Z yeah yeah and then meet
my YouTube you know don't be a stranger
yeah and you don't be a stranger you're
on YouTube yeah exactly
well no more JK party but you can find
her on her personal stuff and you can
find this podcast on all platforms we're
talking about the iTunes we're talking
about the Spotify and everything else
man so if you guys have any questions or
comments below leave it in the comment
section and then we'll see you all next
time [ __ ]